PROFESSOR: OK, well I'm
going to start now.
As I say, I know that the
wireless course has its final
at 11:00, so we might not see
the people who are taking it.
Is anyone here in the
wireless course?
OK.
Q.E.D. Ipso facto ergo sum.
OK, just to remind you, I think
we have Problem Set 10
solutions today.
In any case, they'll be
available on the web.
The final is next Tuesday.
Do bring calculators
if you have them.
They won't be absolutely
essential, but
they might be useful.
You may bring five
sheets of notes.
It's a good exercise
to make these up.
And otherwise, it's
closed-book.
Ashish will hold a review
session tomorrow, 4:00 to
6:00, 26-328, which I'm sure
will be excellent as usual.
All right, just to remind you,
we're in Chapter 14.
Most of the course we talked
about coding for power-limited
channels, where basically you
could get away with binary
codes with very little
loss of optimality.
For bandwidth-limited, additive
white Gaussian noise
channels, we've got to
consider non-binary,
multi-level codes, we've really
got to go out into
Euclidian space and use
Euclidian distance as our
metric rather than
Hamming distance.
So we started out with a simple
idea, build a lattice
constellation.
A lattice is an infinite set
of points in end space that
has a group property.
That's it, a discrete
set of points.
We take a finite set of them by
chopping out a region R, a
compact region, which chops out
a finite number of points
in this lattice or in a
translate of the lattice.
And we went through this
exercise of computing the
union-bound estimate, which I
remind you is a reasonable
estimate for codes that
are not too complex.
We're not going to use this for
capacity-approaching codes.
But for codes, where...,
basically dominated by minimum
distance properties, how many
nearest neighbors are there,
the likeliest error events are
all to the nearest neighbors,
we can use the union-bound
estimate, which basically just
tallies the probability of error
to the nearest neighbor
events by the union-bound, which
itself is inaccurate if
you get too many near
neighbor events.
And we've got this nice
approximate expression that
the probability of error per n
dimensions, if we're signaling
in n dimensions, is the number
of nearest neighbors in the
lattice times the Q to the
square root of a function
times an expression, which
involves a coding gain of the
lattice, and separably a shaping
gain of the region
times 3 times SNR norm.
So this embodies all kinds
of simplifications.
It separates the effects of the
lattice and the region.
Basically, we can optimize each
of these separately to
optimize this expression.
And also, by the way, by talking
about SNR norm, which
is SNR normalized by 2 to the
spectral efficiency, it makes
this whole expression
independent of rate or
equivalently independent
of spectral efficiency.
We saw this back when we talked
about m by m QAM, we
got a universal expression.
The probability of error was
simply this expression with a
3SNR norm in here - regardless
of what m was (regardless of
how big the QAM constellation
was), we got the same
approximate expression.
So this is also independent of
the size of the constellations
in this large constellation,
high SNR approximation.
Once you get to enough points,
everything sort of washes out.
So it's very useful.
And I remind you that the coding
gain basically depends
on the minimum square distance
normalized by the density of
the lattice, if you like,
normalized to two dimensions.
The shaping gain is basically
the shaping gain of an n-cube
divided by--
this is the normalized second
moment of an n-cube, this is
the normalized second moment of
your region, which better
be better than that of an
n-cube, meaning smaller.
And writing it out, it's equal
to this, where this is the
second moment of your region.
And this is the volume, again,
normalized to two dimensions.
So the baseline constellations,
we showed
these were invariant to
Cartesian products.
In any number of dimensions,
n, we can take the integer
lattice or any translate of the
integer lattice and we can
take a region, which
is the n-cube --
which will chop out basically
a square or cubic
constellation, a regular
constellation in n
dimensions--
and we'll get that the coding
gain is the shaping gain is 1.
So we'll get just our baseline
expression for any integer
lattice shaped by an n-cube
centered on the origin.
And this is what
it looks like.
This is back from Chapter
Four or whatever.
We get this universal curve,
the baseline curve, which
holds for m-PAM, m by m QAM, or
you can Cartesian product
these up into as high a
dimension as you like.
The constellation we're talking
about is really m-PAM
Cartesian product to the nth.
For any of those constellations,
if we
normalize the probability of
error to two dimensions--
which is what I'm recommending
to you, normalize everything
per two dimensions in the
high SNR regime--
then we basically get the number
of near neighbors in
Z-squared, the QAM lattice,
which is 4 times Q to the
square root of 3SNR norm.
And it looks like this.
We plot probability
of error per two
dimensions over SNR norm.
I think at 10 to the minus
5, it's 8.4 dB.
Does anybody remember?
But it's somewhere
around 9 dB.
And the Shannon limit, as
we recall, is for SNR
norm, it's at 0 dB.
So this is where we can play.
Any code will fall somewhere
between these two curves, and
the name of the game is to get
a code the gets as close to
the Shannon limit as possible.
And at least in this moderate
complexity regime, the way we
play the game is we try to
optimize the shaping region,
we try to optimize the lattice,
we're going to get a
certain gain from shaping, and
a certain gain from coding,
de-rated by the number of
nearest neighbors, which is
going to turn out to be an
important effect for some
well-known lattices because
they have huge
numbers of near neighbors.
And that will give us some curve
somewhere in here, and
we plot that and we're done.
We've written a paper for
that particular lattice
constellation, for
its performance.
Today I'm going to talk quickly
about shaping, because
that's a very easy story,
and obvious, and
it won't take long.
Then I'm going to talk about
lattices, which is really a
subject in mathematics, what's
known about lattices.
I guess the decoding part of
that story is not mathematics.
That's engineering.
And then I'm going to talk about
trellis codes, which are
the analog of convolutional
codes, and which, similarly to
the way convolutional codes
beat block codes for the
bandwidth for the power-limited
regime, trellis
codes tend to beat lattice codes
in terms of performance
versus complexity for the
bandwidth-limited regime.
So, shaping.
Shaping is really an almost
trivial story.
This really wasn't recognized
as a separable issue until
perhaps sometime in the '80s,
when trellis-coded modulation
was invented.
In '82 was Ungerboeck's paper.
That was really the
breakthrough in
bandwidth-limited coding, that
trellis codes were the first
bandwidth-limited codes that
were widely implemented.
And after people analyzed them
for a while, they realized
that you could separate out the
shaping effect from the
coding effect, which is what
I've shown by this expression.
So anyone care to guess what
the optimum region is in n
dimensions?
I guess I've already mentioned
it last time.
The optimum region, what
do we want to do?
We want to minimize the
normalized second moment--
well, a second moment with
appropriate normalization,
what would you do?
Well, the optimum region for
just about anything is an
n-sphere, and it certainly
is here.
So we take Rn equals
an n-sphere.
If we have a two-dimensional
sphere, what are its
parameters?
We certainly know that the
volume of this region, if this
is R, it's pi times R squared.
And the second moment of this
region, how do we do that?
We integrate ... go to polar
coordinates, 0 to 2pi,
d pi, 0 to R, rdr.
And then what are
we measuring?
The second moment is r squared,
but we normalize it
per dimension, which is 2.
Oh, and we've got to take the
uniform distribution over v of
R, and that's one over
pi R squared.
So have I got it now?
This is the second moment of
a uniform distribution, a
probability distribution
over the 2-sphere.
And so this will be 1 over
2pi R squared times
R 4th over 4, right?
Is that all correct?
And so p of R over v of R is
already not normalized to two
dimensions, so we don't have
to re-normalize it.
I didn't get the 2pi in here.
I need some help, class.
When it comes down to
integration, I'm not
necessarily the world's best.
So R squared over 4...
R squared over 4pi R squared,
so we get 1 over 4pi.
Is that right?
That looks about right
because it's fairly
close to 1 over 12.
So what is the shaping
gain of a 2-sphere?
And I can just say 2-sphere,
because I know it's invariant
to scaling.
Rotation isn't going
to do much to it.
It's 1/12 over this, the
normalized second moment, 1
over 4pi, which is pi over 3,
which is about 2/10 of a dB.
OK, so I've improved the second
moment by 2/10 of a dB,
reduced it to 2/10 of a dB.
This is not very impressive.
So of course, a lot of the
early work was on shaping
two-dimensional constellations.
And this basically says if you
get a large constellation, you
don't even see this effect
to, say, 64-QAM.
If you have a 64-QAM
constellation, 8 by 8--
Somebody at Paradyne noticed
that you could improve it
slightly by taking the four
corner points out and putting
them up here, without reducing
the minimum distance.
OK, so there is an improved,
more spherical 64-point
constellation.
It's improved by about 0.1
dB, as I remember.
And what this calculation says
is if you go up to 256, 1024,
and you simply take all the
points in the QAM grid that
are surrounded by a sphere of
appropriate size to pick out 2
to the n points, for high, large
constellations you get a
gain of about 0.2 dB.
So this is nothing to
write home about.
What happens as n goes
to infinity?
We look up in a math book what
the expressions are for the
normalized second moment--
actually, you can do it just
by this kind of calculation.
It's easy enough.
And just by scaling, you'll find
that the shaping gain of
the n-sphere goes to pi times
e over 6, which is 1.53 dB.
A famous number not only now
in shaping, but also in
quantization, where you're also
interested in minimizing
the second moment of a
quantization cell.
Or it's something like 0.229
bits per two dimensions, is
another way of expressing it.
All right, so what is this?
This is the maximum shaping
gain you could get by the
optimum region in the optimum
number of dimensions, which is
as large as you can go.
So this says this is the
ultimate shaping gain.
You can never get a shaping
gain of more
than 1 and 1/2 dB.
So it says when we play this
game, we've got about 9 dB
down here that we want to make
up at 10 to the minus 5, 10 to
the minus 6, we can get only 1
and a 1/2 dB of it by doing
good shaping in large
dimensions.
That's the best we
can ever do.
So that's a little
bit discouraging.
It says shaping is never going
to give you that much.
On the other hand, you can't
get this 1 and a 1/2 dB
in any other way.
If you have n-cubed
constellations, you will
always be limited to be
1 and a 1/2 dB away
from the Shannon limit.
So if you want to approach the
Shannon limit, you do have to
address the shaping problem.
You can't ignore it.
1 and a 1/2 dB is enough to be
noticed in most applications,
so you should do some
moderate shaping.
Now, of course we can
plot the curve.
It's done in the notes for any
n whatsoever, and you'll see
that it goes up fairly
steeply at first.
It gets to about 1 dB at 16
dimensions, so if you shape in
a 16 dimensional sphere, you
can get 1 dB out of this
maximum of 1 and a 1/2
dBs you can ever get.
If you go to 32, it's 1.2 dB
or something like that, it
begins to slope out.
So that gives you a good
idea of what you
can actually attain.
In the V.34 modem, for instance,
a rather simple
shaping scheme is used that
gets up to about 0.8 dB of
shaping gain.
It's called shaping
on regions.
I just mentioned some techniques
for shaping.
As with a lot of things, once
shaping was realized to be a
separate subject from coding,
there was a flurry
of activity on it.
People basically proposed a
number of different schemes,
particularly in the context of
the V.34 modem standards
development.
Of which trellis shaping,
I would
say, is the most elegant.
This is kind of a dual to
trellis-coded modulation where
we use trellis codes for shaping
rather than coding.
So that's elegant.
But a cruder and quite
effective, just fine
technique, shell mapping, was
used in the V.34 modem.
The basic idea here is that
you take a two-dimensional
constellation, you just divide
it into shells like this.
It turns out in two dimensions,
if you take a
constant delta here, that the
average energy goes up, I
think, linearly with delta or
some way nicely with delta.
You take a constellation bigger
than you really need,
so you have the possibility
of some redundancy.
So you identify each point in
the constellation by which
region it lands in.
You then go up to 16 dimensions
or something--
I think it is 16 dimensions
in the V.34 modem--
and you assign each series of
points a score depending on
which shells its
points land in.
And you basically have a big
table that chooses the lowest
energy combinations from all the
possible series of eight
shells, which can be done
fairly elegantly using
generating function
techniques.
I realize this is just
hand-waving and you can't get
it, but the effect is that you
use this shell with very high
probability.
You sort of get a Gaussian-like
probability on
the shells.
Let me just draw
that like this.
You don't use the points
out in this
outermost shell very much.
You use this a lot, and they
sort of have an overall
Gaussian distribution.
And I should mention that this
is an equivalent way of
getting shaping gain.
If we're shaping uniformly over
an n-sphere in a high
number n of dimensions and we
basically have constellations
which consist of two-dimensional
QAM points,
what is the projection of a
uniform distribution over an
n-sphere down onto
two dimensions?
If we look at each
two-dimensional component of
these n-dimensional vectors,
what distribution will it have
if we impose a uniform spherical
distribution on the
high dimensional
constellation?
It will turn out that it
becomes Gaussian in two
dimensions.
Think of the projection of the
2-sphere down on one dimension.
The projection of a 2-sphere
on one dimension is
something like this.
It's not Gaussian, but there's
more probability that one of
the coordinates will be near 0
than it will be out at one of
these maxima here.
So this is just the same thing
raised up to n dimensions.
So an equivalent way of looking
at this problem is we
want somehow to get a
Gaussian-like distribution on
a one- or two-dimensional
constellation, and this is one
way of doing it.
And you can get the same pi
times e over 6 factor by just
looking at it from an entropy
point of view, the entropy of
a two-dimensional Gaussian
distribution relative to the
entropy of a uniform
distribution over a square.
That will give you the
same factor if you
do everything right.
OK so basically, shaping
is easy.
These techniques are not
difficult to implement.
You can get one dB of shaping
gain quite easily through a
variety of techniques.
It's worth getting that one dB,
you're not going to get it
by any other means.
But having done that, that's all
you're ever going to get,
and so end of story
on shaping.
So as I said, it was a flurry
of activity in the '90s, and
no one has looked at
shaping since then.
So that's part of the story.
Let's continue now with
lattices, an old
mathematical subject.
So what we're interested in is,
what's the densest lattice
packing in n dimensions?
This appeared in mathematics,
long before it appeared in
engineering, as Hermite's
parameter.
And Hermite said this was the
right way to measure the
density of a lattice, normalized
in all the
appropriate ways.
So any version of a lattice
is equivalent.
A version is something that you
get by scaling or rotating
or even by Cartesian products,
which I'm not sure how
widespread that idea is.
So what's the densest lattice
in two dimensions again?
We want to find the densest
lattice, in terms of coding
gain or Hermite's parameter
in n dimensions.
Anyone care to guess what the
densest lattice in two
dimensions is?
It's the hexagonal lattice.
So in two dimensions, hexagonal,
which reasons of
mathematical history
is denoted A_2.
And its coding gain, I believe
we computed it last time, and
it was 0.6 dB.
So what's the most we could ever
do by fooling around with
two-dimensional constellations?
Suppose I want the best
possible 256 point QAM
constellation?
Well, according to these large
constellation approximations,
the best I could do would be to
take the 256 lowest energy
points in some translate of
the hexagonal lattice.
So I might fool around with
the translation vector a
little bit to try to find the
absolute lowest energy point,
but it really wouldn't
matter very much
regardless of what I did.
I could expect 0.6 dB of coding
gain and 0.2 dB of
shaping gain, or 0.8 dB better
than the 8 by 8 - sorry the 16
by 16 QAM constellation with the
same number of points and
the same minimum distance.
This basically tells you
what your options are.
2D, there's not much to do.
You remember way back in Chapter
One, I gave you this
problem about the 16 point,
2D constellation.
That is precisely 16 points from
a certain translate of
the hexagonal lattice that fall
within a circle that's
just big enough to enclose
16 points.
And it has, I forget, something
like a 0.7 dB gain
over the 4 by 4 square
constellation.
We computed that in the
very first homework.
So again, staying to
two dimensions,
things aren't very exciting.
Turns out, it's most
interesting to go
in powers of two.
In four dimensions, the densest
lattice is something
called D4, Schlafly's lattice,
1850-something.
And its coding gain is precisely
the square root of
2, which is 1.5 dB.
8 dimensions, it's E8, Gosset's
lattice, about 1900.
The D4 and E8 come, again,
from the mathematical
literature and have something to
do with their relationship
to certain groups.
Lattices and finite groups are
very closely connected.
And this has a coding
gain of 2 or 3 dB.
16 dimensions, it's something
just called lambda 16.
It's a Barnes-Wall lattice, as
all of these are, actually.
And it's 2 to the
3/2, or 4.5 dB.
You see a certain
pattern here?
In 32 dimensions, we have two
lattices that I'll mention.
There's the 32-dimensional
Barnes-Wall lattice, which has
a coding gain of 4.6 dB.
Or there's actually Quebbeman in
the '60s, I think, came up
with a denser lattice.
So this is still a subject
of active investigation,
particularly in dimensions like
19, where it's not so
easy to find the densest
lattice.
And this, I forget,
is maybe 6.2 dB.
It's definitely denser.
But it's something like that.
This basically goes
to infinity.
You can get denser and denser
lattices just by following
this chain here which is a chain
of Barnes-Wall lattices.
The nominal coding gain can be
taken to infinity, just as we
saw with kd over n.
That goes to infinity for rate
1/2 Reed-Muller codes.
But of course, Shannon says we
can't ever get more than 9 dB
of effective coding gain here.
Or actually, we can't get more
than 7 and a 1/2 dB if we take
into account that 1 and a 1/2
is going to be given by
shaping gain.
So what must be happening
here?
We must be having a huge number
of near neighbors.
The number of nearest neighbors
in the hexagonal
lattice is six.
In D4 it's 24, in E8 it's
240, in lambda 16
I think it's 4320--
the correct numbers
are in the notes.
By the time we get up here, we
get something like a 146,680
or something like that.
So these lattices are designed
to have a very
high degree of symmetry.
That means if you stand on any
point, you look around you,
they've pushed the neighboring
points as far away
from you as they can.
But now there are a great many
of them, so you get a uniform
sky just filled with points
around you, a number of
dimensions.
So that's what the problem is
and that means that the
effective coding gain--
I again do the calculation.
I know here we lose
at least two dB.
This is something like 3.8 dB.
OK, so the effective coding gain
actually sags and begins
to top out as you
get out here.
Maybe nowadays you could think
of implementing a larger
lattice, but I think this is
the largest anyone has ever
thought about implementing.
And what do we get?
A coding gain of less
than 4 dB --
an effective coding gain.
So if you use that,
you'd be, say,
somewhere around 5 db here.
We go over 6 dB, but then we go
up by this normalized per
two dimensions, so
we divide by 16.
That's still 10,000, which
is still 13 factors of 2,
which is 2.6 dB.
You can see where
the problem is.
So anyway, we get something
that's really this moved way
up a lot more, and as a result
we get a much steeper curve.
This method doesn't work up
here, but this might be lambda
16 or lambda 32.
And then we can get another 1
and a 1/2 dB of shaping gain.
So maybe 4 dB, optimistically.
OK, not really.
So that's a little
disappointing.
Just by looking up in the math
textbooks, we don't do very
striking things.
I mention in particular the
Barnes-Wall lattices, and if I
had more time I would develop
them because they're very much
analogous to the Reed-Muller
codes.
They are constructed by a u, u
plus v construction in the
same way as Reed-Muller codes.
They are length-doubling
constructions that also double
the distance, just as the
Reed-Muller codes do now
Euclidian distance.
But let me just give you the
first couple of sentences in a
discussion of the Barnes-Wall
lattices, which were only
discovered in '59, about
the same time as
the Reed-Muller codes.
Suppose we take the QAM
grid like this.
An important observation is that
if we take every other
point in sort-of checkerboard
fashion, what do we get?
Imagine it's going to infinity
in both directions.
So this is a subset of half
the points, basically.
Half the density, twice the
volume of points that, itself
is a rotated and scaled version
of the integer lattice.
Take the centers on a
checkerboard and they form a
45 degree rotated and square
root of 2 scaled version of
the integer lattice.
If this had minimum squared
distance 1 between points,
then this has minimum squared
distance 2 between points.
So we could label the
points red, black,
red, black, red, black.
If we did that, the red points
would be a co-set of this
sub-lattice and the black points
would be a co-set--
meaning a translate--
of this sub-lattice.
So let me write that
as follows.
If we take Z-squared, it has a
sub-lattice which we call RZ
squared, r for rotation.
Rotation by the Hadamard matrix,
1, 1, 1 minus 1.
If I write d min squared, this
has d min squared at 1, this
has twice the d min squared.
So I partition my lattice, or
any translate of this lattice,
into two co-sets of the
sub-lattice with twice the
minimum squared distance.
This is the first steps in what
Ungerboeck called set
partitioning.
So it's an obvious way to
partition any QAM-type signal
set, red and black points.
Having done that, I
can do it again.
Alright, do it again,
what do I get?
So now I'm going to take every
other one of these points,
which will leave me, say,
these 4 points.
Let me call these A, A, A, A.
These points might be B, B, B,
B, the other ones
that I cut out.
I could call these C, C, C,
C and D, D, D, D. Now I've
partitioned each of these
subsets into two subsets.
I've partitioned one into A, B
and the other into C, D, such
that - what does A look like?
A is another translate
of a lattice.
This happens to be Z-squared
scaled by 2.
It's not rotated, it's just
Z-squared scaled by 2.
So we get down to 2
times Z-squared.
And what's its minimum
squared distance?
AUDIENCE: 4.
PROFESSOR: 4.
So I've doubled the
distance again.
This is an elementary but
important observation.
I can continually go
through these,
partitioning into two subsets.
Every time I do, I double
the distance.
I get another version of the
integer lattice at a higher
scale and, perhaps, rotated.
So if I did it again, I would
get eight subsets with minimum
squared distance 8 between
points in each subset.
So it's just a repeated
divide-by-2 scheme.
All right, now to get the
Barnes-Wall lattices, you
remember how we got the
Reed-Muller codes.
We took, say, two codes of
length 2 and we put them
together with the u, u plus v
construction and we got codes
of length 4 that had the minimum
square distance of the
higher distance code, if
we chose them properly.
That's the same thing
we do here.
If we put together these two
lattices, if we choose them--
well, just use the u, u plus v
construction where u is from
Z-squared and v is
from RZ-squared.
So in words, that's
what you do.
If you're interested in
looking it up, look
it up in the notes.
What you get is a lattice, D4,
that has normalized density
halfway between that of
Z-squared and RZ-squared, it
turns out--
sort of analogous to the code--
and its minimum square
distance is 2.
Or if you put these two
together, you get something
called RD4, whose minimum
square distance is 4.
So you get something whose
normalized volume is halfway
between that of these two
normalized volumes, but it has
the same minimum distance as
this guy, and that's where you
get the coding gain from.
This is denser but still has
the same minimum distance.
If we do this again, go out to
eight dimensions, we get, it
turns out, E8.
And this has minimum
square distance 4.
But it has the same normalized
volume normalized back to two
dimensions as this guy, which
only had minimum squared
distance 2.
So that's precisely why
this has a nominal
coding gain of 2.
We've doubled the minimum
square distance without
changing its density, normalized
back to two
dimensions.
All right, so you get all the
Barnes-Wall lattices just by
doing this.
This turns out to be a
sub-lattice of this guy.
Not surprisingly, just as these
lattices are nested,
just as the Reed-Muller codes
are nested, so you get a
similar tableau.
You get a similar construction
that you can take out to 16
dimensions, 32 dimensions,
however many
dimensions you want.
And every time you do, you
increase the coding gain by a
factor of square root of 2, so
the coding gain eventually
gets driven to infinity,
and that's the story on
Barnes-Wall lattices.
So similarly to Reed-Muller
codes, these are lattices that
are the densest known in certain
small dimensions like
4, 8, and 16.
We don't know any
denser lattices.
You start to get up to 32, 64
dimensions, then we do know of
denser lattices.
But they are not nearly as
nicely structured, and maybe
these are still the best from
a complexity point of view.
You can play similar games
on building trellis
representations of these
lattices, as we did for
Reed-Muller codes.
They have similar kinds of
trellises because they're
based on the same
construction.
So that's the story of
Barnes-Wall lattices.
The most famous lattice is the
Leech lattice, which is a
super-dense lattice
in 24 dimensions.
It has a coding gain of 6 dB.
And unfortunately, it has
195,560 near neighbors or
something like that.
So you can see, it turns out
it's a very close cousin of
this 32-dimensional Barnes-Wall
lattice.
It's related to the 24-12-8
Golay code in the same way as
the Barnes-Wall lattices are
to the Reed-Muller codes.
So the fact that the Golay code
is so exceptional can be
seen just as a projection of
the fact that the Leech
lattice is so exceptional.
This somehow has the Golay code
buried in it, if you can
find it in here.
And the Leech lattice is
particularly notable not just
because it has remarkably
high coding gain for its
dimension-- it's remarkably
dense for its dimension,
exceptional--
but also because it has
remarkable symmetries, so it's
connected to some of the largest
exceptional groups,
the monster exceptional
groups.
And it was a key step in the
classification of all finite
groups to find the symmetry
group of this lattice.
Just a little liberal
arts for you.
So that's what we can
get with lattices.
By going out to the Leech
lattice or the Barnes-Wall
lattice-- this could equally
well be the Leech lattice--
again, effective coding gain
is only about 4 dB or maybe
even less because of the
exceptional number of near
neighbors here.
To one digit of significance,
that's approximately its
coding gain.
So how can we go beyond this?
As I said already, the next
great breakthrough was trellis
codes for which Gottfried
Ungerboeck became famous.
Trellis codes, as I say in the
notes, are basically--
first of all, Ungerboeck thought
about the problem from
a Euclidian distance
point of view.
So what you had to do
to break out of
Hamming distance thinking.
He had the idea that in the
bandwidth-limited regime, what
you want to do is expand the
constellation rather than
expand the bandwidth.
So to send four bits per
second per Hertz.
You could do that using uncoded
16-QAM constellation.
Or Ungerboeck saw, well, let's
make it into a 32-point
constellation.
Now we have some redundancy, now
we can do some coding on
this constellation.
He used the set partitioning
idea, which I've just
explained to you.
Initially, he just looked at a
QAM constellation and he said,
let's divide it up into A, B, A,
B, C, D, C, D, A, B, A, B,
C, D, C, D. So let's partition
it from A, B, C, D into A and
D as I've done it here, and B
and C are these two subsets.
And we'll break this up into A
and D and B and C. And then
some theoretical people came
along and said, well, this is
just Z-squared, this is
RZ-squared, and this is
2Z-squared.
Let's, first of all, partition
our enlarged constellation.
Now here's the setup we're
going to use for coding.
We are going to bring in our
...If we're trying to send--
I forget what notation I used in
the notes-- b bits per two
dimensions.
Let's take one bit per two
dimensions and put it into a
rate 1/2 convolutional code.
So we're going to get
out two bits.
Everything here is going to be
per two dimensions because
we're going to use a
two-dimensional signal set.
And we'll bring in our other
b minus 1 bits down here.
These are called uncoded bits.
For these two bits,
we're going to go
into a subset selector.
Two bits are going
to select among--
this going to be something from
A, B, C, or D. It's going
to tell us which
subset to use.
All right, then we'll use that
in combination with these b
minus 1 bits to select a point
from a 2 to the b plus 1 bit
QAM constellation.
Two dimensions.
So this is actually our signal
point y, our two-dimensional
signal point.
Do you see how the
numbers work out?
We want to send b bits per QAM
point, per two dimensions.
We're going to use a 2 to the b
plus 1 point constellation,
so 32 instead of 16, say.
Take one bit in here, generate
two streams, one redundant.
This will tell us A, B, C, D, so
that's two of the bits you
need to select one
of these points.
Say, in a 16-point
constellation, we'll provide a
bit label that looks
like this.
For A, it will be 0, 0. b is
0, 1, c is 1, 0, D is 1, 1.
That's always the low-order bits
in any selection for A,
B, C, D. And then we'll take
two high-order bits, which
then tell us which of these
four groups it's in.
So we'll have another 0,
0, 0, 1, 1, 0, 1, 1.
Now I'm talking about
b equals 3.
We have two bits that come in
here and select one of these
blocks, and then two bits that
come out of here and select A,
B, C, D within the block.
There's two parts
to the label.
One of them determines A, B,
C, D, the other one just
determines some larger group.
These bits are called uncoded
because there's no protection.
If you sent point A over here
and received point A over
here, that would look
like a perfectly
legitimate code word.
If we make an error of that far,
which is d min squared
equals 4, say.
We make an error of size d min
equal 2 all the way over here,
then there's no further
protection from this code
because this code only
determines the sequence of As,
Bs, Cs, and Ds.
This is called a within-subset
error.
There's no protection on
within subset errors.
What the code does is it
protects against smaller
errors that are between subset
errors like A to B, which has
squared distance of 1 or A to
D has a squared distance of
two, and so forth.
Are you with me?
Nobody's asking questions.
Maybe I haven't permitted it.
Do you follow what the
overall setup is?
I've done everything now,
except choose an exact
constellation.
For the exact constellation,
I'll just choose one of the
best QAM signal sets.
If it's large enough, I'll
shape it like a circle.
Or I might even try to put
Gaussian shaping on it by some
completely extraneous
thing that works
only on these clumps.
So shaping takes place on
the higher order bits.
You can see that, given a large
enough constellation
just by choosing these clumps,
I can make the constellation
sort of have the shape
of a circle.
The subsets of A, B, C, and D
points have to all be the same
size in order for this
scheme to work.
But I can do that within a sort
of circular constellation
if the constellation
is large enough.
Or I can put some Gaussian
distribution on these clumps.
So I do shaping down here.
Initially, of course,
Ungerboeck
didn't worry about shaping.
But if I try to do shaping, it's
down on this index, which
is considered to be the higher
order bits that determine the
growth structure of
the constellation.
These are the lower order bits,
these two bits, and they
determine the fine structure
which is
determined by this code.
So the last thing I have to
select is the code, and it
turns out that the same code
we used in the example is a
good code to use here.
Suppose we use the four-state
rate 1/2 example code that
I've used before that is
everybody's favorite example
because it has such excellent
distance properties.
So it looks like this.
So that's my rate 1/2 encoder.
You remember as a binary code,
it had minimum Hamming
distance 5.
And the only minimum
distance code word
was the impulse response.
Let me write the impulse
response as this
way: 11, 01, 11.
This is what we get out at time
0, time 1, and time 2.
Let me assign the following
labels to these subsets.
We'll make that 00, this
one 11, this one 01,
and that one 10.
In other words, this is the
complement of that.
This is the complement
of that.
What is the nearest neighbor
point in Euclidian space for
this sequence?
If I complement the first two
bits coming out, then I'm
going to go from one of these
subsets to another, but within
one of these RZ-squared subsets,
which has minimum
squared distance 2.
So let's remind ourselves that
the minimum squared distance
within A, B, C, D is 1, within
A, D or B, C is 2, within
2Z-squared is 4.
So I'm claiming--
there's actually a problem on
this on Problem Set 10 if you
tried to do it--
that any error of this type,
11, is going to cause me a
Euclidian error of minimum
squared distance 2, at least.
It can only cause me to go from
A to D, which is always
at least squared distance 2, or
from B to C, or vice versa.
So in terms of Euclidian
distance, d min squared, I'm
always going to get a squared
distance of 2 at this point.
And actually, any place you
diverged in the trellis,
because of the structure
of the code, this
is going to be true.
I'm always going to get a
squared distance of 2 when two
trellis paths come together
in the trellis.
I always have a binary
difference of 11, so by the
same argument I'm always going
to get a Euclidian squared
distance of 2 when two trellis
paths come together.
And furthermore, I'm going to
have at least one difference
somewhere in between, which is
going to, again, in terms of
Euclidian distance, lead
to a Euclidian
distance of at least 1.
So the conclusion is that
between any two sequences of
constellation points that are
labeled by two distinct code
words here, I'm going to have a
cumulative Euclidian squared
distance of at least 5, by the
same argument as I had for the
binary code.
But now it turns out that I'm
still in a regime where binary
distance, Hamming distance
translates directly to
Euclidian distance.
This is what you saw.
Basically, what we're using here
is this is Z-squared, you
can think of as the image of
the (2, 2) binary code.
RZ-squared is the image of the
(2, 1) binary code, and this
2Z-squared is the image of
the (2, 0) binary code.
You get the same partition
structure for these codes and
their co-sets.
This is the set of all
four two-tuples.
We divided it into two subsets,
each of minimum
distance 2 here, and here we
divide it into four subsets,
each of minimum distance
infinity.
I'm not going to take the time
to make this precise, but
think of how that
relation goes.
So I've assured myself of a
Euclidian squared distance at
least 5 between signal point
sequences that correspond to
two different code words.
That's excellent.
Is the minimum squared distance
of the code then
equal to 5, as it was in
the binary case of
this trellis code?
No, it's not.
And the problem is I could make
this kind of error, which
is completely invisible
to the code.
I can make a within subset
error, and this only has
minimum square distance of 4.
So the conclusion of this
analysis is that this is
what's called a four-state
two-dimensional trellis code.
This four-state two-dimensional
trellis code
has a minimum squared distance
of 4, and it has a number of
nearest neighbors per
two dimension of 4.
That's the number of nearest
neighbors within 2Z-squared,
which is one of these subsets.
So the conclusion is that
already, this has a legitimate
3 dB coding gain.
Its coefficient is still just
the QAM coefficient, and this
very simple code has this
performance curve moved over.
So it's 3 dB all the
way up the line.
So that's pretty good.
This is a trivial code that
could be decoding--
by the way, it was, again, done
by the Viterbi algorithm
of a four-state trellis.
You just take the sequences
and it's exactly the same.
You measure distance in terms
of minimum squared distance.
The only difference is when
you decode, you first find
what the closest point
is within the
A, B, C and D subsets.
That is what you're going to
take as your representative
for that subset.
So you first make basically an
uncoded decision, which is the
closest point in A?
Which is the closest point in B,
which is the closest point
in C, which is the closest
point in D?
You're going to get a metric
for each of those.
How far is each of those
from the receive point?
So then in trellis decoding,
what the trellis is going to
look like is something
like this.
A, D, A, D, B, C,
and so forth.
The trellis is going to look
exactly the same, but here you
get A, D, D, A, B, C, C, B.
So what metric are we
going to use for
each of these branches?
First, we find the closest point
within each subset, and
then we use the metric
for that point.
Clearly, if we're going to
choose A for this time
interval, then we should use the
closest point in A as our
receive decision.
We can get that survivor without
any memory whatsoever
when we make that decision, and
then we take the sequences
of representatives and find
the best of those
representatives as our best
trellis-coded sequence.
Any sequence of points that has
labels that correspond to
some path through this
trellis is a valid
point and vice versa.
If and only if the sequence of
labels is according to this
trellis is it a legitimate
trellis-coded point.
So it's a nice amalgamation.
Great.
With a simple four-state code,
basically we've doubled the
size the constellation.
The constellation expansion is
2, the constellation expansion
factor with twice as large a
constellation, we've been able
to achieve a coding
gain of 3 dB.
Not bad.
So how do we extend this idea?
First, extension would be to--
all right, let's go up
to an 8 state, 16
state, whatever code.
But is that going to improve
our minimum distance using
this block diagram?
It's not, because we're
still stuck with this
within subset distance.
So we can never get past d min
squared equals 4 with a
four-way partition.
What we have to do is make one
more level of partition and we
need to make an eight way
partition, at which point
we're going to get a within
subset distance of 8.
I left out one step,
I'm sorry.
I'll come back to it.
We can get a code minimum
squared distance up to 8, if
we extend the minimum squared
distance up to 8.
The thing I didn't use, I didn't
tell you before, was in
computing the coding
gain of this code--
let's just call it c--
what should it be?
It should be the minimum squared
distance of the code
over the volume of the code
per two dimensions.
In this case, n is 2 so I'm just
going to do it over the
volume of the code.
Now what is the volume of
a convolutional code?
This is actually an interesting
problem, because
the Voronoi region of a trellis
code is actually an
infinite dimensional object.
A trellis code is really an
infinite dimensional lattice.
It's a lattice in infinite
dimensional space.
And if you look at the Voronoi
region, it extends out into
all these dimensions.
It might not for such a
simple code, but in
principle it does.
However, you can find other
fundamental regions.
The way to think about
this is instead of
putting the volume here--
well, what have we cost
ourselves in volume?
We've doubled the size
of the constellation.
And in two dimensions,
that means
we've doubled the volume.
So we've quadrupled the minimum
distance at the cost
of doubling the volume.
We've covered twice as much
space now because we have
twice as many points.
And so, that's where
we get the--
this is equal to, for
this code, that's 4.
We have a factor of 2 loss in
volume, and so that's where we
get what I said was a coding
gain of 2 or 3 dB.
Just to get you to the bottom
line, we should replace the
volume by two times--
I call it eta of the code--
where eta of the code is its
redundancy per two dimensions.
In this case, we introduce
one redundant bit per two
dimensions, and that's why the
constellation has to expand by
a factor of 2.
You see, we get the
right answer.
The redundancy has increased by
one bit, so this has to be
2 to the b plus 1, so the
constellation has to be twice
as large, so the volume
is twice as large.
I'll just hand-wave and tell you
that's the factor you want
down here representing
volume --
2 to the redundancy.
And you can prove this by
finding a region which you can
show is a fundamental region
of the trellis code and has
this volume.
But I won't go into that.
OK, so that's the calculation
which I should've mentioned
before, I skipped
right over it.
Back to what I was saying.
To improve trellis codes, the
first thing you can do is to,
say, go to an eight-way
partition.
So now we're going to
have eight subsets.
So we're going to need
three bits here.
So let's use two bits here and
use a rate 2/3 trellis code.
We're going to have three bits
coming out here to select
subsets, and we're going to have
b minus 2 bits down here
to select a point still
a 2b plus 1 point QAM
constellation.
So our redundancy per two
dimensions is still one bit
per two dimensions.
We're still going to lose a
factor of 2, but now we can go
up to d min squared equals 8 and
we can go up to a coding
gain of 6 dB.
So in his original paper,
Ungerboeck did this.
He showed codes going up to 256
states in two dimensions
that gets you up to a nominal
6 dB coding gain.
And because they have low
coefficients here, they get
very close to 6 dB of effective
coding gain.
Already in Ungerboeck,
we have codes--
I mean, eventually you can get
back to just the within-subset
coefficient again, which
is always 4.
You can get up to, say, 6 dB
with maybe 512 states of
effective coding gain, which
is considerably better than
the densest lattice we would
think of using, and also quite
reasonable to implement.
Now we're going to need
a 256, 512-state
Viterbi algorithm decoder.
This was a stunning
breakthrough.
Immediately in 1993, everybody
started building turbo codes.
Back in 1982, everybody started
building trellis codes.
It happened to be the time of
the V.32 modem, and everybody
said boy, this is just what we
need to get an additional 3 or
4 dB coding gain in
the V.32 modem.
What was actually done there
is this was simply an
eight-state convolutional code,
so it was rate 2/3.
And there was tweaking
of this.
It was made rotationally
invariant, made nonlinear.
And a lot of activity, which was
very nice, stimulated by
the standards effort.
But that was basically the state
of the art in the '80s.
The one other improvement
that was made was
the following idea.
We really don't like doubling
the size of the constellation,
particularly for a large
one, mostly for
implementation reasons.
There were some feelings against
nonlinearities a
larger constellation
would cost you.
You wanted to minimize the
constellation expansion ratio.
So how were we ever
going to do that?
You can't do it this way
in two dimensions.
The way to do that is to go
up to four dimensions.
So let's do subset partitioning
in four
dimensions.
So now think of four dimensional
constellations.
In practice, these are just
built from the Cartesian
product of two two-dimensional
constellations.
We start with Z4.
The next one down is D4,
which has a minimum
square distance of 2.
It's sometimes called a
checkerboard constellation in
four dimensions.
It's just the red-black
idea again.
Then below that, we have a
four-way partition into RZ4,
which still has minimum
distance 2.
And one more level of
partitioning here into
something into RD4, which has
minimum squared distance of 4.
So this is an eight-way
partition of a
four-dimensional
constellation.
This idea was introduced
by Lee-Fang Wei.
Again, this is an interesting
column over here.
You can think of this as being
the (4, 4, 1) code.
This is the Euclidian image
of the (4, 3, 2) code.
It kind of expanded
in the lattice.
We know we can't do any
better than (4, 2, 2).
Down here, this is the
(4, 1, 4) code.
So again, this is the same
partition as we get for binary
codes with the distances--
again, for binary codes and this
level of partitioning,
Hamming distance translates
to Euclidian distance.
It's really just the image of
these codes as you go up to
the lattices.
Now in this case, what's the
best we can ever do?
Coding gain.
We still can't go up to a
squared distance of greater
than 4 because our within-subset
distance is
going to be within RD4.
So this is still limited to 4.
But now, what's our redundancy
per two dimensions?
Here, say, we're going to
use still a rate 2/3
convolutional code.
We'll now have an eight-subset
selector in 4D, so everything
is per 4D here.
So this is going to be 2b minus
two bits and this is
going to be, it turns out, a
constellation that is twice as
large in four dimensions.
We still have one redundant bit
per four dimensions, so we
need twice the size of the
constellation in four
dimensions.
But that's only 1/2 a bit of
redundancy per two dimensions.
So this denominator becomes
2 to the 1/2.
Waving hands furiously here.
And so this could go up to 2 to
the 3/2, which is 4.5 dB.
So there's actually a
particularly nice eight-state
code here that Wei came up with
which, really, in terms
of performance versus complexity
is the only code
that anyone has ever come up
with that is distinctly better
than any of Ungerboeck's
original codes.
All of Ungerboeck's original
codes were in one dimension,
two dimensions, or PSK codes.
You could also do this
on phase shift key
constellations.
So with the Wei code, it gives
you a very simple way
to get 4 1/2 dB.
Actually, you have to go up to
16 states to get 4 1/2 dB.
The Wei code is only 4.2 dB.
And this is basically what was
adopted for standards in the
early '90s.
The V.34 modem standard, also
the ADSL standard has the same
code in it.
If you have DSL at home, that's
what it's using in it.
Again, with a very simple code,
the eight-state Viterbi
algorithm, you can get 4.2
dB of coding gain.
The error coefficient in this
case, this has 24 nearest
neighbors in D4, or 12
per two dimensions.
So you lose 0.15 dB
or something.
I'm sorry, 0.3 dB.
Anyway, this is a
very nice code.
There are 32 and 64-state
codes in V.34.
They don't gain you very much.
They each double the complexity
and only gain you
about 0.2 dB for each one.
All these things tend
to saturate.
You can't get more than about 5
to 6 dB of coding gain with
a reasonable size
trellis code.
So where are we now?
We can get 5 or 6 dB of coding
gain with, say, a 256-state
trellis code.
We can get another 1 to 1 and
a 1/2 dB of shaping gain.
So all together, we're
up to 6 to 7.5 dB.
From here, we're up somewhere
into the 2 to 3 dB range.
In other words, combining
trellis code with, say, 256
states with some shaping scheme
with maybe 1 dB of
shaping gain, this gets you
maybe 5 dB or 5.5 dB.
We get 6 dB total effective
gain, and we're still 3 dB or
maybe 2 or 3 dB from
Shannon limit.
So, close but not
quite there yet.
Five minutes to go.
So in the notes, there's
one page on
higher performance schemes.
There are higher performance
schemes.
There are turbo codes for the
bandwidth-limited regime that
get you to within 1 dB
of the Shannon limit.
Sequential decoding gets you to
within about 1 and a 1/2 dB
of the Shannon limit.
The idea of multi-level
codes --
you can regard each of these
two-way partitions as being
specified by one bit.
So with three bits of labels,
you can specify
an eight-way partition.
Another idea is to code on
each of these levels
separately.
Use a binary code on each of
these levels separately.
Each of these corresponds to an
effective channel that has
different characteristics.
You've basically got to take the
Gaussian distribution and
alias it around in accord with
whatever this partition
actually is.
But you can come up with an
effective binary channel at
each of these levels.
It turns out to be a binary
symmetric input channel,
always in these cases.
So you could think of
taking a binary--
now, each one of these channels
is going to have its
own capacity.
It turns out that information
theoretically, the capacity of
multi-level coding on each of
these levels independently is
the same as the aggregate
capacity of coding it on the
whole channel.
It's a lovely separability
result.
So in principle, if you could
code at capacity on each of
these binary channels, then you
could get to the capacity
of the aggregate channel, with
a large enough constellation.
So that's a good idea.
We now know a lot of binary
capacity-approaching code, so
let's use a turbo code or a
low-density parity-check code
at each level, an appropriate
code.
It turns out, as you might
expect, that the first level
is the really hard level.
In this case, you might have
a rate 1/3 or 1/2 code and
really work hard
with your code.
At the next level, the effective
error probability is
much better.
Making hard decisions, you might
have a probability of
1/10 or lower of making
an error.
So these are really much
easier problems.
It might be a better idea at
these levels just to use
algebraic coding or something
that works very well.
The capacity is nearly one per
bit at each level, so you want
to code with very little
redundancy at these next
levels, but it's still capable
of approaching capacity.
Well, it turns out this is a
good scenario for Reed-Solomon
codes or some kind of
algebraic code.
So the moral is you only
really need your
capacity-approaching code at
maybe the first or first and
second levels.
Down here, just use
a very high rate--
1,023, 1,003 Reed-Solomon code
over gf of 2 to the 10th--
very little redundancy, and
drive the error rate down as
low as you like at each
of these levels.
So multi-level coding is a
good way in principle.
I'm not sure if it's been
done in practice.
In fact, I don't know of any
capacity-approaching code that
has been done in practice,
except there's a very crude
technique, I would say, called
Bit-Interleaved Coded
Modulation, BICM, which is the
following simple idea.
Let's just take a single
low-density parity-check code
or some capacity-approaching
code.
It's going to have to be
designed for a BICM channel.
Let's totally interleave the
bits and then let's use them
as the bits that control each
of these levels here.
At the output of the channel,
we know which level the bits
came out of.
So at the output of the channel,
we know what the
appropriate a posteriori
probabilities
are for each bit.
They're going to be
wildly different.
A bit sent through here is going
to be sent through a
very highly reliable channel,
a bit sent through here is
going to be sent through a very
low reliability channel.
But with all this interleaving
and the independence
approximation in the analysis,
we're going to be able to
design a code for this mixture
channel, a mixture of high
reliability and low reliability
binary channels,
that's going to get to the
capacity of this mixture
channel, which as I've already
told you is equal to the
capacity of the aggregate
channel.
I guess there's some elegant
features of it.
But that's, in practice,
what people use.
They use it more because they've
already developed a
chip for binary channels, and
they want to reuse that chip
for some large constellation
channel, some
bandwidth-limited channel.
So this was originally advocated
by Qualcomm as a,
quote, pragmatic approach.
OK, we've got a chip that works
for binary channels, so
let's just interleave outputs
and use it over this
multi-level channel and it'll
probably work well enough.
And, in fact, that's true.
And the information support
for it, again, is the fact
that you don't lose anything
by coding bit by bit from a
capacity point of view.
I think that's the only one
that's been used in practice.
And on wireless cellular
channels for instance, that
tends to be what's used.
And of course, I know that
perhaps a couple of you have
an exam at 11:00, so I'll
make a point of
letting you out of here.
I've really enjoyed teaching
the course this term.
It was the first time I was able
to get to the analysis of
capacity-approaching codes,
so I enjoyed doing that.
At this point, I think the
subject of coding for the
additive white Gaussian noise
channel, the traditional
channel, is pretty
well wrapped up.
I don't think we're going to
see any great improvements.
There's still some very
interesting theoretical
questions about the convergence
of these iterative
decoding algorithms.
What do they converge to?
How fast do they converge?
There are interesting
connections to statistical
physics and inference
and so forth that
people are still exploring.
They're interested in graph
theoretical properties.
There's attempts to
algebraically construct these
capacity-approaching codes, so
we can say a lot more about
their parameters and their
performance, particularly for
lower probabilities like
10 to the minus 15.
So you go to the information
theory symposium, you'll still
hear a lot of papers about
coding effectively for
additive white Gaussian noise or
memoryless binary symmetric
input channels.
But people ask me, is
coding dead now?
Are Fourier transforms dead?
No, they're not dead.
But they've become sort of part
of the standard core of
what you should know.
I think this is a subject that
anyone in communication should
certainly learn, but is it an
area where people are going to
make further advances that are
important from a practical
point of view?
Obviously not very much, in
view of the Shannon limit.
We are very close to the
Shannon limit for these
channels, and have been
now for a few years.
So it's important to know
about these things.
It's important to know when
you're in the wireless course,
for instance.
You basically calculate mutual
information and assume that
you can go at the mutual
information.
This is how you do it.
So you should know how it's
done, and that's why I think
this course continues to
be worth teaching.
But from a point of view of
research, it's become a rather
mature area, and the action
has gone off to
other kinds of channels.
Multi this, multi
that, so forth.
Anything to do with networks
or multi-user is where the
action in coding is.
Data compression, of course, is
a subject that we haven't
talked about at all, which
is also coding.
So anyway, I think it's good for
you to have all this under
your belts.
I hope that you find it useful
in your future lives, and I
wish you all well on
the final exam.
Thank you.